clyde the glide and david robinson  and this one goes for 40. so it's all  eights how's that eight you want to  start out with an eight you don't want  to bring everything out that's solid  solid  yeah i don't know okay i feel like  jaylee green will come on bro man  he's playing catch up now though  yo you what are y'all where y'all didn't  win tim's in chicago what y'all want  whatever we can get our hands on  come on hand me down  clyde the glide and david robinson  and this one goes for 40.  so it's all eight how's that eight you  want to start out with eight you don't  want to bring everything out that's  solid solid  yeah i don't know okay i feel like jayla  green will come on bro man  yo he's he's playing catch up now though  yo do you what are y'all where y'all  didn't win tim's in chicago what y'all  whatever we can get our hands on  come on hand me down